c'est la protéine qui va faire la
fonction de la cellule est-ce que vous
connaissez des exemples de protéines
sensibiliser les jeunes aux malades
génétiqu et à la recherche Laurine
buscara 38 ans et directeur d'études
dans le laboratoire généton à é cour
courouronne le 17 novembre dernier elle
rencontrait une classe de première du
lycée de Villarois à guyencour dans le
cadre du programme 1000 chercheurs dans
les écoles présentation des pathologies
rares et des différents traitements un
travail de vulgarisation nécessaire pour
expliquer l'utilisation des dons de la
FM Téléton et créer des vocations j'ai
vu qu'il y avait quelques élèves qui
étaient intéressés par par la biologie
de façon générale sans pour autant
savoir ce qu'il ce qu'il voulait faire
et voilà ce qui est intéressant ce que
je pouvais peut-être le apporter c'était
que moi non plus j'ai jamais su ce que
je voulais faire vraiment je savais que
j'aimais la bio mais je savais pas
qu'elle quelqu cursus et donc voilà leur
montrer que que dans la bio toutes les
passerelles sont sont possibles est-ce
que travailler à l'étranger ça a été dur
ou pas par rapport à la longue tout ça
après des études en biologie cellulaire
et moléculaire Laurine buscara intègre
le généton il y a 5 ans elle travaille
actuellement sur trois projets de
thérapie génique concernant des
pathologies neuromusculaires face à
cette vingtaine de lycéens en spécialité
SVT la chercheuse a pu présenter sa
profession des explications
enrichissantes quoique complexe je
comprenais vu que précédemment on avait
vu certains points mais à d'autres
moments non j'étais j'avou un peu perdu
au lycée on apprend on voit les matières
tout ça mais rend pas vraiment compte ce
qu'il y a derrière et justement toutes
les possibilités de bah justement de
métier et de parcours donc c'était très
intéressant durant cette 11e édition de
1000 chercheurs dans les écoles plus de
300 établissements ont ouvert leurs
portes dans toute la France une première
approche pour éveiller la curiosité
autour de la science pour les 40000
élèves
participants